hi everyone it's jerry this is game two
from the 2021 fide world chess
championship match between magnus
carlson playing on the white end
and jan nepomnichi
game one was a draw
let's see what happened in game two
move one
d4
game one we had
e4
the opening is a catalan
g3 bishop g2
speedy development
for white's light square bishop it's
already on the main diagonal
and because of this black's light square
bishop will oftentimes
find it difficult to activate
both sides castle
d takes c
and after queen c2 far and away most
popular on this move seven for black
is to play a6
which prepares to meet queen takes c4
with b5 and there you go just in the
nick of time
black is there on the main diagonal
preparing to offset white's
light square bishop
there are deficiencies with this
approach by black
a backwards c pawn
holes along the c file
okay
second most popular
move in the databases is this one right
here
b5
move played in the game
defend c4
but this rook is now a bit more
vulnerable
white strikes at it
black's limited you have to clog up this
diagonal in some way knight d5 is one or
the move played in the game c6
this is a pawn that can be captured in
two different
ways let's not consider this one this
would be giving up a four point minor
piece
fee and cutout bishops pretty important
bishops to hang on to especially if it's
one that's on the king side
without it your king is more vulnerable
let's look at this one
knight takes first and then bishop
this isn't such a great approach for
white you do get the pawn back but this
bishop's in no man's land
um
could easily be struck out
this rook i think is well placed
supporting
queen side majority
nearby there can be a light square
bishop exchange
white wouldn't want that and
black's development looks pretty good
so instead it's a4
thematic rook pawns like to attack
knight pawns
in just a blink this rook can be
activated however
this tension remains for some time and
i'll touch on why that's the case in
just a bit
from here we have the threat of a takes
b
taking advantage of the pinned c6 pawn
bishop b7 is not helping with this
so it's knight d5
and from here we have
knight c3
the knight is given a kick back to f3
this knight was in black's house
um
f6 is considered one of the best moves
if not the best move
but
proceed with caution
when you make those type of moves
that's for sure
all pieces are still on board
and
to make this early commitment with one
of the pawns on the king side
you know
looking long term
you know e6 is a whole now
g7 is a bit more vulnerable should there
ever be a white major piece
on the seventh rank it would be hit
directly this is the heart after all
of black's king side
okay
from here it's queen d7 this is
defending b5 directly
i'd like to highlight in
a big oversight i had
during the live stream on twitch
i was thinking in this position
is there anything wrong with putting the
bishop on b7
there would be a big issue there
so let me show you what this big issue
is
i i thought that a takes b would be able
to be met with
not
simply the recapture white would get the
pawn back
but i thought
black would be able to meet a takes b
with this in-betweener
capturing on c3 and only then capturing
on b5 now this position
is excellent for black
if not
for
this one move
what is that move feel free to pause the
video
okay here we go
catalan players
queen on c2 bishop on g2 knight g5
like that one
that's slick threatening mate
and
the bishop uh the rook and the bishop
white winds
so this natural-looking bishop b7 is not
working queen d7
defends b5
a little uncomfortable to make that
could make that move because the knight
doesn't have access to the d7 square but
okay it is one of the best moves queen
d7
from here e4 white sets that majority
in motion the central majority in motion
proceed with caution
team white when you play e4 because now
d3 is a whole
and it can
well the knight can hop in there in just
a couple and does
along the way with tempo
queen e2
knight d3
does not stay here for long e5
opening up a square for the knight maybe
the queen
primarily the knight likes to be tucked
right behind a pawn
don't forget about that bishop as well
its eyes are back to
being opened can see the queen side
squares as soon as this knight moves
okay so now
black gets on with development of the
bishop
i was pointing out the timing of this
capture let me let me highlight it right
now what was the move played here we
have a capture on f6
why isn't a move like this played well
look it we're helping the rook but also
the bishop
this is a reason to hold off
on
this particular capture
you help the rook but the bishop as well
chop on f6 in this game
bishop recaptures
94 peace improvement
peace improvement
peace improvement
if black is trying to be greedy with a
pawn capture
there would be knight takes bishop
and knight
knight to g5
and this is this is a big problem
what are we doing here
e6 is hit twice there's also the threat
of a fork
that wouldn't be a good choice
so jan gets on with development
knight a6 it is
knight e5
and
from here we have bishop takes knight
now in this position if queen takes pawn
is on board
what can we play here
we can play knight takes bishop
and after rook takes knight we can
capture on b5
that's looking pretty good
this pawn is ready to go into pac-man
mode it's true this knight is hanging
but this is looking pretty serious
after a takes b5
okay
no queen takes d4
instead it's bishop takes knight
you could also look at this one but
this variation right here but that's not
so good because after knight g5 once
more
there's a problem here along the e file
white is converging on e6
so
after 95 its bishop takes knight
pawn takes
and knight c5 so
there are outpost squares on the d file
for each side
for white d6 for black
d3
black is also threatening
with this last move to
win the exchange knight b3
there's a problem on c1
white allows it
jumps into d6 and says this this knight
right here is far more valuable than
three
black goes for the exchange
grabs on c1
rook on b
takes
and
black simply captures the rook on c1
uh
this rook right now
is in a way
overloaded
has the responsibility of defending the
rook and f2 so
some tricks like rook takes f2
might be there but not in
this not in this particular case because
after rook takes
this isn't even the best move there are
many winning moves queen f queen f1
looks pretty nice though
pretty easy to understand what's
happening here
we're attacking the knight and forming
this battery and we're ready to get to
the seventh rank
for kf7
this guy is dead next
so these little tricks on f2 are not
working
black simply picks up the exchange
knight takes rook rook takes knight
it's not just the exchange that black is
up black still has that extra pawn
but
again this knight
more valuable than three and this bishop
less valuable
than
three
uh it's gonna still take some work some
time by black to activate this bishop
and
you know ideas of
getting to these light squares seeing
how this this bishop is not
really able to neutralize this guy so
fast this could be a problem for black
proceed with caution i believe right
around here if i'm recalling correctly
during the live stream
it's saying black is
better when you look at that evaluation
number
but
you know you look a little bit deeper in
this position you
you see that that knight on d6
big piece
the best piece in this position
okay
rook b8
rook d1
setting up discoveries black says go
ahead
i don't care which pawn you take
i'm fine with that
white doesn't bite
uh you could go ahead and grab the b
pawn
and now
once the b pawn is gone all these pawns
are super weak
isolated many cases of isolated pawns
but
instead white
looks to
put some holes in
the black king side create some gaps
carve out some squares
he starts off with e4
bishop e4
preparing to create a battery
h7 is in the
is in white's crosshairs
c3
queen c2
so what are we doing about this thread
on h7
g6
now
if you go ahead and capture on g6 right
here
this is something that definitely had to
be weighed
um but
we're gonna look at that let's first get
this capture and he doesn't capture just
yet goes on c3
and after the capture on a4
let's look at this capture at this
moment
this is not good for white
why not
well
black can take
and after
this black is able to block
and after this one the king goes here
this is winning for black why well
white needs one other attacker he needs
to get this rook involved
needs to get this rook to h4 but
that's not working because rook d4 can
be met with rook b1 check
king g2
ooh that's really going to hurt
discover check
your rook is hit
c5
saves the day
would save the day
so
these
sacrifices on g6 are not working
by the way
after queen c2
we try and
we defend
this is the this is the main way to try
and defend against this pressure we're
trying to
stay strong somewhat as as black on the
light squares
when you play this well
maybe white can
shift gears
and try and sneak in like that
takes many moves but that
yeah that might not be long enough
that can be that could be a big problem
for black
all right
in the game it's g6 staying strong on
the light squares b takes c
b takes a
queen takes a
from here we have rook d8
queen is now defended
black is just a moment away from playing
c5
finally
getting ready to challenge white's light
square bishop
where are we at move 27 yeah
it's taken some time but
just to blink away now is black
and playing c5
rook a1
anticipating that this move is here this
bishop will be captured
and
this knight wants to recapture
so this rook needs to get out of the way
c5 on board
queen c4
this king is the more vulnerable
i didn't highlight this yet
and i should have
when this battery was formed
and g6 is on board
this is a new gap
in black's position this knight
stands well on d6 right now
but is only
two moves away from getting to f6
that can be
a far more
a much scarier
square
for black
if white knight is on
f6 okay after queen c4 the bishops are
exchanged
the knight recaptures with an i and f6
this fork is nearby
in these situations which of these two
should you move first this will land
what move what piece to go with first
the answer the king the one with the
fewest options first
if the knight goes here
only then will you
let white know okay i'm gonna go to this
particular square with my queen
fewer options first go with that one
king the piece with the fewer options so
king h8 is a nice move
and from here i was
thinking the knight was going to jump
right into f6
but it simply returns to d6 it clogs up
these
major pieces they will not see white
side of the board so easily
and
also
we could
we could say to ourself well the knight
stays in a position where
uh it has a check
now something i like to add here is the
possibility for anastasia's mate
this knight on f6
is
pretty powerful let me highlight a
continuation here if the knight jumped
into f6
and black says
well i don't like that
my king is the more vulnerable let's try
and exchange queens
that's a good way to lose white can take
the queen straight away or even be fancy
capturing on a7 say go ahead take my
queen
this is anastasia's mate
powerful knight king in the corner
knight two squares away along the
diagonal
sets this up
of course you could go ahead and take
the queen first and then this
and mate is unavoidable yeah a powerful
piece for sure a knight on f6
plenty of mating nuts
in this game it's knight d6
rook b6 hinting at giving the exchange
back getting rid of the knight
queen takes c5
black doubles
king g2
black could if he wants
uh
he could get rid of the queens right now
with queen c6 doesn't go for that how
might this play out if queen c6 is on
board
this is still
this is this is a pretty drawish
position right here
brook takes pawn knight e4 there's only
one move here
you have to anticipate knight on f6
black would have a
a saving move
preparing to beat knight preparing to
meet knight f6 with rook to b7 some rook
to b7
no queen c6 in this game
instead a6 doesn't even want to give up
that a pawn
so white says well i'm not going to give
you another chance to
exchange queens
queen c6 is not hitting with check
anymore so the white king hides h6
feels a little it looks a little weird
still all major pieces on
on black side at least the king is on h3
it would be nice if this pawn was
already on h4 and then king h3 would
feel
somewhat uh more natural
to not uh have your h-pawn obstructed
and
maybe even look to
push your pawn further to disrupt
black's king side structure
okay
but timing wise it's not there king h3
in this game move 34
rook c6 queen d4
gets out of a check
not saying that's a great move straight
away but
slight improvement for the king
if your knight is going to be on d6 okay
i'm going to put my king on g8
c4 the knight has this responsibility to
defend the pawn so this frees up the
queen maybe to go elsewhere
she does after queen c7 this is now
vulnerable
so white targets that
but black is able to now give the
exchange
back
has that option to take the knight
goes for it
it takes knight
material wise we are now balanced the
black king
is still the more vulnerable
from here it's c5
queen takes c queen takes e with check
after king moves
rook takes a
three versus two pawns on the same side
this rook is not able to get to the
seventh rank though
this gives black time to
organize the pieces rook f8 now f2 is
hit twice defended zero
some check i believe could be met with
rook f7 and you'll be getting this pawn
shortly
so white saves the f-bomb
but now this allows
black to exchange queens
and even though
black is down a pawn since we're working
with pawns on the same wing the king
side
it's tough to
create any winning chances here for
white
let's have a look at carlson's approach
the game does continue
he's still trying to stir up some
trouble
this is
this world chess championship match is a
marathon so maybe some
you know trying to
you know wear out your opponent
over
each and every one of these games let's
see the approach
trying to
extract blood from a stone here
if white is going to have any chance he
needs to disrupt this structure ideally
you want to get this pawn
up to h5 you need to create tension with
the g pawn
so
first step
is to take over control of the fifth
rank
if this rook is allowed to patrol the
fifth rank it's difficult to ever get in
h5
so white kicks the rook off of the fifth
rank and now gets rolling with the h
pawn
i like this next move by black he goes
with king h6
i like this move because if you simply
sit
white can play king g5 this is still a
drawn position but now all of a sudden
black has to ask himself
am i okay with allowing the pawn to get
to h6
it's two steps away from queening
there's still this guy in its way but do
i want to allow this pawn to get to h6
how how do i feel about that structure
or
do i give the white king a kick
and then allow this
exchange to eventually happen right
that's that's unavoidable this exchange
will will happen am i okay
with giving white a past f pawn
there's it this is still considered a
draw but
there's a little more concern i believe
black would have with this particular
structure
if it's the case
where
these pawns are simply exchanged
this is much easier to defend this there
are no past pawns present for white in
this scenario
okay so i like king h6 because you don't
even allow the possibility of king g5
and you don't have to deal with
maybe uh
not a capture but you have to consider
should i allow that pawn to get to h6
alright king h6 in this game king h4
rook a rook a1 g4
carlson's still trying so if black does
nothing let's say brings the rook back
is this going to be all right for black
the computer says yes but
i don't know if you really want to allow
that
it's not
it's not it's not as clear we want to
get
pawn exchanges in there we don't want to
allow this guy to get to the sixth
establish
himself on that sixth rank so
black is there in time in this game to
give some checks
inconvenience the king
capture on h5
if you take like this we're
we're just this is this is a draw
the idea here by white is to meet this
capture with a check
and preserve this pawn now white has a
passer but it's balanced
two pawns a piece not the healthiest of
pawns
continuing another check
rook is always in a position to rattle
the defending side here black is always
in a position to challenge that white
king
so there we go rook a4 pressure on this
guy
king f3 rook a3 king f2 rook a4 and at
this point
a draw was agreed to
game 2
ended peacefully but a fighting
another fighting drive saved a more
more of a fighting draw than game
one um
very interesting middle game why is this
why is this final position a draw is
there something else white can try
let's say king g3 and rook a3
and suppose the king tries to hide here
black can follow up with rook f3
and how are we
how we defending this pawn
rook f6
black can follow up with h6
can't do that drop the rook
and if rook takes pawn there's rook here
king takes pawn and now this rook comes
back and the king is ready to be
challenged
along the h file g-file f-file
some other variation not sure
what more to try here
let's say king takes pawn
we can take here
king takes pawn
and this two
is going to be a draw
the rook has to have some fun giving
checks
rook here
yeah there's probably other draws as
well the rook can come over
no
no good
winning chances here for white
in this ending so it ended peacefully
after
move 58
about a four and a half hour
uh game too
so let's have a look at
uh the tail of the tape on this one
and we can see that these guys continue
to play super
super accurate what did it ever get down
to minus 0.8 but yeah with those
imbalances
even even though it's getting to this
what minus 1.5
that knight on d6 that white knight on
d6
quite the piece and eventually it was so
annoying
black went ahead and gave the exchange
right back
it's quite the flat line here from move
28 on
at the end of the day what do we have
average senti pawn loss
nine for carlson 10 for napomnichi
we remain deadlocked going into game
three
okay well that's all for this video
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
in the comment section below
i hope you enjoyed it
and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now
take care bye